por qué
[Música]
o no
i
yo le dije
[Música]
y
y esa forma de agustí está compuesta por
términos que son casi matemáticos
aplicados de la manera correcta funciona
hoy
vengo de una localidad al sur de la
provincia de santa fe xy sea bajarle un
pueblo muy chiquito con la
característica propia
por eso
he desarrollado el vértice tanto sea por
la vocación de servicio como también por
mi empatía en empresas de primer nivel y
si me encantan los lindos desafíos
pasa por el año 2010 desarrollo de
emprendimientos
y aplicarlo
ya nivel a2 equipo
en el preciso instante en el que le pido
permiso a mi equipo digo bueno me voy a
presentar a un concurso en ese concurso
lo que voy a hacer es presentar un
producto que justamente tuviese que ver
con el tema de la ecología valga la
redundancia
fue así entonces que en ese momento
desarrollé h 24 h 2 pot era una maceta
que lo que hacía era rescataba todo el
vidrio de una botella y en el cual se
desarrollaba una planta que daba un
ahorro de agua porque porque la planta
consumía el agua que necesitaba o sea
que era un mensaje para el consumidor
respecto del consumo responsable
obviamente la maceta ganó el primer
premio de ese concurso y tuve la mala
suerte de que tuvo una aceptación en el
mercado de consumo rotunda
tuve la mala suerte de que la prensa
especializada en el sector de ecología
lo pusiera inclusive como uno de los 15
mejores productos a nivel global
respecto del mensaje que daban de
consumo responsables y ecológicos como
también por su desarrollo porque digo
mala suerte porque tenía un defecto de
diseño
en el vaso inferior cuando la planta
crecía se partía y esto podría ser
solucionado solamente con una máquina
que venía de bélgica no de otro lugar
en ese momento por la transición
económica que teníamos no se podía traer
a inviable traer la máquina como así
también ingresarla al país y el zumo no
ocurre cuando un excelente cliente de
capital federal hace una compra grande y
el 80 por ciento de nuestras macetas
llega roto
fue mucha la bronca la decepción y la
frustración pero lejos de tirarnos para
atrás convoco a mi equipo y le digo
vamos a tener una reunión urgente vamos
a dar un giro de 180 grados
vamos a desarrollar otro producto porque
porque la prensa y todo eso nos había
dejado colocados dentro de bien
posicionados como echos diseñadores
en este desarrollar entramos a
investigar obviamente todos los
materiales y dijimos
vamos a utilizar algo que tuviese que
ver cómo fue la botella o sea que
tuviese que fuese ecológico que fuese
innovador y por qué no que también se
basa un mensaje
en ese momento por cuestiones de la vida
me sigue un consejo a la mente que nos
daba donjuán que en paz descanse un
amigo de la familia en el cual él era
vivir era electricista de vídeo y
siempre me decía hijo cuando vos
desarrolles algo o utilices herramientas
o productos para hacer algo trata de que
sean con elementos que puedas conseguir
aún un domingo a las 12 de la noche
reúne al equipo y con estas cuatro
consignas que sea ecológico que sea
innovador que se ve un mensaje y que se
hiciese con materiales que pudiésemos
conseguir aún un domingo las doce de la
noche desarrollamos un brainstorming o
sea una tormenta de idea para esa nación
investigando elegimos como material el
plástico porque elegimos el plástico
porque aunque ustedes no lo crean
es increíble la cantidad de plástico que
tiramos por día en nuestro país se tiran
500 mil envases plásticos por hora el
equivalente a 12 millones de envases
plásticos por día si ustedes lo quieren
dimensionar esa cantidad es tan grande
como todo este teatro pero multiplicado
por seis
son seis teatros de estos uno arriba del
otro
preocupado por esto seguimos
investigando y otra agencia de opinión
pública que nos da otra noticia peor el
53 por ciento de los argentinos le
interesa poco o nada los temas de
ecología o no sabe por qué no está
informado pero ahí había una luz en el
túnel
qué pasó la misma agencia nos informa
que seis de cada diez personas de
nuestro país están interesadas en
recibir información respecto de temas
que tienen que ver con ecología el
tratamiento de los residuos etcétera
entonces por ahí vamos a entrar porque
el problema no eran solo los residuos
sino que también era la falta de
educación
convocó nuevamente una reunión a mi
equipo y le pido que por favor traigan
todo el plástico que tienen en sus casas
que vienen de su uso de uso cotidiano
los ponemos sobre una mesa y entramos a
investigar a desarrollar no nos daba
nada no nos salía nada entonces en un
momento de bastante bronca
sale un pensamiento en el cual digo si
para el cartón
hay campañas para el pez para las
botellas hay campañas hasta para las
tapitas hay campaña agarro un envase de
shampoo y con bronca lo tiro la cruz
sobre la mente digo qué hacemos
con los cuerpos y digo la palabra cuerpo
y le digo y si hacemos un muñeco
y si hacemos un muñeco
lo que son papas lo entendieron
y fue así
y dijimos vamos a hacer un robot
justamente con las consignas y las
premisas que habíamos dicho que fuese
ecológico que fuese innovador que diera
un mensaje y obviamente hecho con
material que conseguimos en casa a uno
en domingo los 208 desarrollo que
tuviese que ser articulado que cada una
de sus partes se notaran que estaba
realmente hecho con material que no
estuviesen deformados sino que estaba
hecho
con el residuo que tenemos diariamente
en casa así nace potito este es nuestro
primer robot lo hicimos a las apuradas y
corriendo apenas lo terminamos fuimos a
la casa de mi amigo pizzi y ronny que
son amigos buscando una opinión objetiva
de un amigo
que nos dijese si realmente estamos por
el camino correcto que tratase de ver si
nuestra intuición estaba bien es
realizada que nos iba a decir
ustedes me preguntarán qué pasó después
fue un éxito rotundo votito entró en un
montón de lugares fue su juguete que
estaba destacado de un montón de premios
pero no obstante eso queríamos ir un
poquito más allá entonces con daniela mi
compañera de vida de trabajo y que me
ayuda en esto de jugar y crear creamos
un kit este kit que nosotros creamos la
idea era que fuese para que toda la
gente pudiese armar sus propios votitos
que la gente tuviese a mano el método
para que para resignificar nuestros
residuos para dar una segunda
oportunidad para que pudiésemos crear
nuestros propios juguetes pero también
para rescatar aquello que hacíamos con
nuestros abuelos que era jugar en
familia
entonces de esta manera no solamente
rescatamos al el familiar sino que
también estábamos dándole un mensaje
cuidando el planeta
fue así entonces que voto fue elegido de
interés provincial por la cámara de
senadores de nuestra provincia fuimos
elegidos como uno de los mejores
emprendimientos sustentables del país
tengo la posibilidad de haberlos
presentado en museos de arte moderno
como el malva en el museo de ciencias
naturales de rosario entre otros muchos
lugares en los cuales les puedo decir
pero no obstante eso y por analogía me
permitió también como tengo una
experticia en ecología participar de
mesas del desarrollo sostenible en el
cual tomamos decisiones representando a
la ciudadanía y toman decisiones que se
va a hacer en la provincia respecto de
temas en ecología tuve la suerte de
poder dar charlas a nivel internacional
para enseñar consumo responsable también
pude intervenir en acciones educativas
por parte de la nación
y también estoy interviniendo espacios
públicos donde podemos rescatar como
este último 2 de julio en el norte de
catamarca donde tuve la posibilidad
junto a mi equipo de intervenir un
observatorio astronómico escolar al cual
ahora tiene la palabra inclusivo
porque porque justamente lo que hicimos
fue participación ciudadana
tratamos de con esto rescatar los
valores de pertenencia fue tan exitoso
que más de 1500 personas fueron a la
inauguración
si ustedes me preguntan es todo
satisfacción si what it o fue creado
justamente por para dárselo al mundo y
un poco le voy a traer alguna historia
para que lo referencia
un día estábamos exponiendo el rosario
en una es posible en una feria de diseño
muy importante en la cual había
exposición y venta entonces sucede que
realizamos una venta se lo llevó una
mamá al otro día el canal 3 de rosario
nos hace una nota entonces empezó a
venir más gente entre esa gente que vino
mucha aparece la mamá nuevamente pero
con otra persona con una mujer se acerca
a mí y me dice botín si tienes más
robots negros
si yo generalmente cuando uno va a una
exposición de venta y justamente para
exponerlos a parte del arte se va a más
y los tiene bajo me fijo y había cinco y
se me llevó a los cinco
cuando toma los 5 obviamente mi
curiosidad fue muy grande porque porque
la elección y empiezan a cuchichear con
esta persona que había venido
entonces me doy cuenta de que había un
interés bastante profundo en el robot
que se agarra y me dice que intrigada
por que compre cinco robots negros y
dice tengo una excelente posición
económica y le podría comprar el mismo
cualquier juguete que quisiese mi hijo
tiene autismo
yo siempre le compro juguetes en la
garra los mira en el envoltorio y los
guarda hacer por primera vez lo vi jugar
después de ocho años fue la primera vez
que lo vio jugar entonces dices voy a
llevar todos y sé la persona que me
acompaña es la psicopedagoga y ahí ella
agarró y me dijo mira la clave del robot
es que no tiene expresión entonces no
tener expresión acompaña al chico en que
si él está contento está contento si él
está triste estás triste o si está
enojado el robot también está enojado
esto como una anécdota personal pero
también tengo otra en la cual me
presenta una curaduría justamente para
otro concurso de diseño de un arquitecto
muy circunspecto sin saludar me hace
pasar a una sala donde tenía exponiendo
mi robot
entonces se agarra de una manera
bastante despectiva pregunta por qué
hiciste esto en referencia al rol nos
buscó un poquito la pregunta entonces
tomé aire y le dije no entiendo la
pregunta sí sí sí porque hiciste esto
entonces respire y le dije lo hice para
trascender
perdón sí sí sí para trascender pero no
como diseñador lo hice para trascender
en mis hijos y en los hijos de mis hijos
y en los hijos de cada uno que tiene un
robot o que puede hacer su robot porque
porque el plástico tarda 400 años en
degradarse entonces es un mensaje que
ellos pongo en una botella y los lanzó
400 años adelante
dando un mensaje concientizador pero no
solamente eso pidiéndole disculpas a esa
gente por el planeta que le estamos
dejando
muchas veces le comento a mi amiga anto
qué
si ustedes me preguntan cómo hice got it
o got it o nunca lo hice pensando que
era mío lo hice pensando que era para
todos por qué digo esto porque cada
persona que puede hacer su propio voto o
que puede adquirirlo de alguna manera lo
lleva como una bandera y si lo lleva
como una bandera está llevando su
propósito no solamente el mío está
haciendo una causa común porque porque
las intenciones que tiene el producto
son buenas porque yo puse toda mi
capacidad en esto porque porque
aprovechó cada oportunidad que ustedes
me dan como clientes en cada una de las
cosas que realizan y por qué no en cada
robot que construyen
le voy a presentar
a mi hijo
potito
[Aplausos]
me acuerdo qué
cuando el equipo de casilda a quien le
agradezco la oportunidad nos convoca a
esta reunión me preguntan cuál es tu
profesión
y yo le dije mi profesión es intentar
porque vivo intentando
por eso eso ahora les voy a proponer a
ustedes que sean intentar es como
profesión que disfruten de cada éxito
que tienen y que vean cada error como un
aprendizaje generen anécdotas porque al
fin y al cabo una vida sin anécdotas no
es vida
entonces soy en la tarde
les voy a dejar la fórmula
como le dije casi matemáticas suerte es
igual a capacidad más oportunidad sobre
la intención
si son sinceros con ustedes mismos y
ponen en cada lugar lo que corresponde
yo les puedo garantizar que funciona
muchas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y